so we got the story from Pew research
it's uh almost a year old it says about
four in ten U.S adults believe humanity
is living in the end times
periods of catastrophe and anxiety such
as the pandemic have historically LED
some people to anticipate to the
destruction of the world as we know it
the end times is near
take a look at this U.S Protestants in
Evangelical and historically black
Traditions especially likely to believe
humanity is living the end of times
among Christians 49 say no 47 yes
Protestants 55 yes Evangelical 63 yes
historically black 76 percent say yes
interesting interestingly Catholics 70
say no
and uh among the black population 68 say
yes now among all uh U.S adults 58 say
no 39 say yes but uh you do the math on
the bell curve and uh you know where you
think the people who are right are gonna
do how many people they pulled for this
is that on there uh let's see do they
should they do normally say
these are really interesting numbers
like 1300 it's really disappointing you
know like we pulled 270 people and
extrapolated it to 300 million oh look
at this a slight majority of Americans
believe Jesus will return to Earth one
day well the Christ energy is due for a
return I don't know it has anything to
do with Jesus Christ or not it doesn't
have the immediate number right up at
top and I'm not seeing the number of
those what happens when people get
desperate enough when the cycle calls
for it someone like that will rise up
and speak and it's like it comes out of
you it's not like you're not just 10 000
10 156 us adults that's a lot that's a
lot for opponent that is a massive
sample size I don't think we're in the
end of time I don't think that
everything's gonna be about to end but I
think we're at the end of a cycle like
the internet has created the beginning
of a new cycle so we are now facing the
end of the yeah like that that song it's
the dawning of the age of Aquarius which
is I think the year 23.50 or something
so we're we're coming up on the Dawn of
Aquarius right now and there you go you
want to know something like so the 2012
apocalypse you know do you know the
actual word for the apocalypse is like
it's truth coming to light it's an
Awakening it's not like the sky's on
fire it's actually about things coming
to knowledge and what's Wild is like
where the Revelation because it reveals
it's coming to light yeah right just
want to say that yeah it's wild
um and do you guys want to hear some
other scripture that talks about yeah so
this is wild I've been going down this
rabbit hole and so like again like I
said I've been studying pole shifts and
you know as the science shows
geomagnetic pole shifts it's not that
the Earth flips upside down
um it's just that the interior of the
core Transitions and can cause effects
on Earth but I am not convinced that
there isn't a tumble
um and so listen to this scripture
Joshua 10 13 it says so the sun Stood
Still and the moon stopped till the
nation Avenged itself on its enemies as
it's written in the book of jashar the
sun stopped in the middle of the sky and
delayed going down about a full day uh
uh what and let me do one more and this
is from the Quran book 48 he who seeks
repentance from the Lord uh or Allah
before the rising of the Sun from the
West before the day of the Resurrection
Allah turns him to his mercy so it talks
about the day when the Sun rises in the
west now just to clarify the actual
um it's believed that that just has to
do with when you pass away you go into
the West so it's not talking about the
Earth
it is what I'm trying to say is that I
am I know that the other side will say
that's not a correct translation for it
but when I see that prior scripture from
the Bible talking about the Sun and the
Moon standing still uh and then I see
this it would mirror if there was a pole
shift where the Earth actually did a
tilt some portion degree so I'm just
sharing this stuff because someone wrote
this down a few thousand years ago and
thought it was important to preserve it
I bet I'd have the correct translation
I'd love to see what the live chat says
just share well so this is interesting
apocalypse to us in colloquial English
means end of the world end of days it
the literal translation is revelation
quite literally comes from the Latin
church Revelation and really interesting
2012 time frame with the iPhone like I
know the iPhone was born what 2008 but
when you look at like this period of
time when most everyone started getting
a smartphone in their hands yeah Market
saturation yeah all the time that 2012
because in my end so it was the end of
an era in the beginning of a new age
starting and at the beginning of the new
age the yeah basically like everyone
started having a smartphone and everyone
was connecting the internet everyone
uses that Facebook every single day is
most of me at their house and you know
look where we are now I guess I think
the the Aquarius the age of Aquarius is
due to begin about 2600 CE which is what
is CE the same thing as a d yes okay
yeah they stopped doing 80 because yeah
he was religious that's very offensive
okay very offensive
BCE Before Common Era it all makes sense
and I wonder how much is BCE yeah BCE
before coming around and it's all just
it's all the same thing as the look
Roman or what is Greco-Roman is what
they were called but it's just new names
so that way you know it doesn't affect
atheists A.D means uh anno domini the
year of Our Lord yeah and they used to
actually say
1653 the year of Our Lord crazy oh wow
and now they say Common Era I wonder how
much you say BC and a d here think about
how ridiculous is that they canceled
time like like that's in BC it's like so
that doesn't count I'm stealing this
joke from Louis CK but he made that joke
it's like so 2500 years ago was negative
time sorry you know we're gonna say well
I don't know how much of this is like
self-fulfilling prophecy style or if
we're actually in the apocalypse if it
like do you believe that the Bible I
mean you strike me more as an
archaeologist than anything but like do
you believe I don't know if you have to
go to school to become a technical
archaeologist is that the way it works
let me just say I'm not an archaeologist
I I am a independent researcher I went
to school for business and
Communications religious studies I am
just somebody that I I go down these
rabbit holes and and I am I I look at
what the they say on the so-called
mainstream side I look at what The
Fringe says I look at what the
conspiracy theories uh Theory say and I
kind of just think for myself I wonder
if the Bible actually portented what the
future or if we're just kind of looking
at it and like making it fulfilling the
prophecy subconsciously or it could be
that's an excellent question and
sometimes it makes me wonder that us
humans when I look at the works of the
philosophers of old you know uh Plato
Socrates Aristotle and you look at if
you just sit down and read their works
I'm like they literally have The Human
Condition down to a T so I I speculate
that it's just the way we are and over
time it's gonna get it just repeats
itself and that you have the tyrants you
have these weirdos that just want to
control everybody else and it's just the
same system goes on and on again because
that is the way the human brain is wired
like everyone at this table might not
want to be king of the universe but
unfortunately there are people that
really get off on that and I don't know
why I don't it's not going to bring them
any happiness but this is just seemingly
the way it just keeps going and going
and going I don't know do you see like a
way to change it Awakening
um I think that um look I would say
probably psychedelics I've had some
moments where I've had you know like it
gives you that it's about the ego death
all right hippie easy there
um but like honestly like teens I think
that maybe this is how it's supposed to
work like I I am a believer that this is
we are part of something very special I
believe in intelligent design I think
that this might be a big this could be a
big dream for all you know I don't know
I think that maybe this is yeah and so
simulation would would imply you don't
have to call it God but whatever it is
Creator and so I'm like if that's the
case this could be maybe this is a test
maybe this is supposed to be how it goes
the simula I have a problem with the
simulation Theory and the simulation
theory is good entertainment yeah this
is a fun time right it is better than
nothing right yes not for some people
dude the problem with the simulation
theory is it only moves the the goal
further away it doesn't answer any
questions all it does is say okay well
our reality is a simulation that means
that there's another reality outside of
ours what made that there's however
however it may be that space reality
it's not even a question it's known
possible but then so the simulations
purpose could be what would what would
human life be like without knowing
with so imagine this imagine we live in
a simulation that was created quite
literally to test the faith of people
who aren't given a definitive proof but
are told to believe whereas in base
reality they quite literally have Jesus
like come down and be like hey everybody
you know here's the latest update from
God and they're like oh okay it could be
you know this could be a big test just
like that and I I think it'd be smart
for people I like the way Dr Jordan
Peterson puts it that believe in
something even if it doesn't even exist
you're better off and I think that
people should operate as if they're
being this will sound crazy to some
people but you should you should live
your life like you're on the world stage
that the the cosmos are watching and
what you do matters and that after your
life maybe there's a judgment maybe
there isn't but I assure you that your
life and the whole world would be a lot
better if you operated that way yeah act
like act like that I think that Peterson
is on to something when he says you have
to act like everything you do matters
because if the things that you don't do
don't matter what's your point of doing
them like what's the reason for you to
get out of bed what's the reason for you
to do anything if the things you don't
do actually don't matter and if they
don't matter then and and if you can't
find a reason that's where you find
nihilism that's where you find
hopelessness that's why you find
depression that's where you find all
these negative things because people
need a reason I've said this before I
think that this is just my personal
opinion but I think that uh religion is
a psychological phenomenon that cannot
be separated from human beings which is
why the government tends to supplant
organized religions in atheist or
agnostic societies because human beings
don't get the option of not having Gods
you can you can as an individual not
have one but your Society is going to
orient itself towards something whether
it be
a God or an ideal or whatever and if
that if what your Society is organizing
itself in pointing itself towards is not
productive for humans if it's anti-human
you destroy your society and we've seen
multiple Societies in human endless
Societies in human history be completely
wiped off the Earth where there's plenty
of of you know societies and
civilizations that have gone the way of
the dodo bird and that's likely because
they have their society organized
improperly thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time